right now Congress is considering two
bills that could potentially turn the
United States into a centrist censorship
zone just as it's similar to China
what's happening is two bills one is in
the house of representative is called
SOPA the others in the Senate called the
protect IP act these are terrible bills
that would authorize the Attorney
General to order internet service
providers search engines advertisers
advertising networks people who process
payment transactions on the internet to
go to them and force them to suspend
their services to certain websites that
are deemed to be hosting illegal
material there is no due process for the
for the websites that are affected by
this there are all foreign websites
under these bills and therefore not
subject to the ordinary kinds of
protections that we would expect in a
country that supports free speech we we
think these are terrible bills and we
are trying to stop them so please help
contact your Congressman your
representative and make your feelings
known the more we speak out against this
the sooner we can stop it thank you